الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى نشره
الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها بابرز
العناوين
موسكو تعتبر تدمير سدك خوفك هجوما ارهابيا
مخططا له في كييف وخبراء يحذرون من عواقب
بيئيه قد تستمر للابد
وفاه جميع مرضى غسيل الكلى في الجنينه غرب
دارفور بسبب عدم توافر المواد الطبيه
وخروج المستشفيات عن العمل
السفيره الامريكيه في وكاله الطاقه تدعو
مجلس المحافظين الى الاستعداد لمحاسبه
ايران
توقف انش
طه طليه ودوريه
في سربا الشمالي افغانستان
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه ما تزال قضيه
تدمير سد نوفاكا خوفكا تتفاعل سياسيا
بيئيا وانسانيا
مجلس الامن الروسي نيكولاي باتروشيف وصف
تدمير السد بانه هجوم ارهابي خططت له كييف
بتنسيق مع الدول الغربيه واشار الى ان
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وشركائهما في
الناتو ينسقون انشطه كييف وانهم مسؤولون
عن الموقف في كهوفكا
تدمير سد نوفا تسبب في حدوث فيضانات شديده
في منطقه خرسون جنوب اوكرانيا حيث يعمل
رجال الانقاض على اجلاء السكان من مناطق
الخطر وقد غمرت مياه الفيضانات الشوارع
بينما كان الناس يبحثون عن الامان على متن
شاحنه وفي قارب
ين
لمزيد من المتابعه تنضم الي مراسله
العربيه كاتيا اهلا وسهلا اذا كانت موسكو
متاكده تماما انك والغرب هما وراء تفجير
سد كخوفكا فالسؤال المطروح كيف سترد موسكو
كانت هل تسمعيني
كاتيا على الهواء يبدو ان الاتصال طيب هل
سمعت السؤال او اعيده عليك
تعيد السؤال
اذا كانت موسكو كما قال سكرتير مجلس الامن
القومي وكما قال الكرملين متاكده تماما ان
كيف والغرب هما وراء تفجير هذا السد
كخوفكا فالسؤال المطروح كيف سترد موسكو
يعني هل من حديث عن طبيعه الردود التي
ستقوم بها موسكو نتيجه تفجير هذا السد
مرحبا طالب بالفعل كان الاتهامات التي
صدرت اليوم سواء كانت عن لسان
سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي او الخارجيه
اعتبرت ان اوكرانيا هي التي تقف اولا خلف
هذا
الحادث الذي وقع يوم امس او طبعا كانت
وصفته بالارهابي وكما تحدث سكرتير مجلس
الامن ان واشنطن انه برعايه غربيه برعايه
واشنطن ولندن هم هما من اعطى الموافقه على
اجراء مثل هذا
الشيء لذلك كيف او موسكو هي تقوم ستقوم
بالرد كما توعد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي
الذي تحدث اليوم بان روسيا سترد على هذا
الفعل وان روسيا ستقوم ضمن اطار او ضوء في
ضوء العمليات التي تقوم بها كييف وهي
العمليات الهجوميه الاخيره ستقوم بايقافها
عن حدها وبالتالي فيما بعد بعد انتهاء هذه
العمليه العسكريه للسيطره على جميع المنا
ستقوم بالقضاء على مركز صناعه القرار وهنا
الحديث
طالب عن الرئيس الاوكراني هذه هي المره
الثانيه التي تحدث فيها سكرتير مجلس الامن
في ضوء هذه الاحداث عن امكانيه تصفيه
الرئيس الاوكراني من قبل موسكو وانه هو
الهدف الاساسي الان في الضربات الروسيه او
في محاولات طبعا
التصفيه الاخيره كنا قد شاهدنا اعلانات من
قبل
المؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه انها قامت
بتصفيه احد صناع القرار في اوكرانيا لذلك
لا نستمتع لا نستبعد ان يكون هناك استهداف
شخصي الان من قبل موسكو للرئيس الاوكراني
هذه التطور الاحداث الاخيره الذي شاهدناه
الايام الاخيره
هل هنالك اي حديث في موسكو عن اي محاوله
لاصلاح او ترميم السد ام لا يعني هذا السد
لا يمكن ترميمه خصوصا وان الحديث يعني انه
نتائج ضرب هذا السد ستكون وخيمه على القرم
لانه القرم سيعاني من العطش شبه جزيره
القرم اضافه الى الكثير من المواطنين
الروس في الدومباس هل هنالك حديث في موسكو
عن اي محاوله لاصلاح السد ام لا هذا غير
مطروح
طالب من المبكر الحديث عن امكانيه اصلاح
السد الان لان الان
سواء كانت القوات المواله لروسيا على
الارض هناك او القوات الروسيه الان
والطوارئ هي الان تعمل على
استيعاب ما جرى او كل هذا ما جرى من خلال
التفجير السد طبعا كما تعلم هناك 35 منطقه
سكنيه الان
غرقت نتيجه هذا
التفجير بالاضافه الى هناك نحو 15 15 الف
منزل تدمر وغرق نتيجه تدمير اسد لذلك الان
من المبكر الحديث عن امكانيه ترميم هذا
الساده الان الحديث يدور فقط عن امكانيه
اجراء المواطنين الروس عفوا المواطنين
القاتنين في تلك المناطق بالاضافه الى ذلك
الحديث عن امكانيه السيطره على امكانيه
حدوث تلوث نتيجه تفجير السد كما تعلم كان
هناك حديث لخبراء يتحدثون عن وجود
عم بسبب ركود الماء في هذا ما نتناولناه
بالامس وسنتناوله اليوم كاتي هذا الموضوع
ولكن وانت تتحدثين الخبر العاجل الان
الجيش الاوكراني يؤكد الجيش الاوكراني في
خرسوني يؤكد ان العديد من الجنود الروس
قتلوا واصيبوا بتفجير سد كخوفكا يعني هذا
الكلام ياتي عن الجيش الاوكراني انه متاكد
انه في جنود رؤوس قتلوا في هذا التفجير
يعني هذا الكلام له دلالات طيب وزير
الدفاع سرقه اكد انه الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد بدا هل لهذا الكلام دلالات معينه
يعني عندما يقول الروس انه الهجوم المضاد
قد بدا هذا ما الذي يعنيه
كما تحدث اليوم
كان قد قال ان بالفعل الهجوم الاوكراني
كان قد بدا وهو طبعا كان ليس بالمفاجاه
لموسكو لانها كانت تتوقع في ظل جميع
المساعدات العسكريه التي تتلقاها كيف بان
يكون هناك هجوم مضاد من قبل اجانب
الاوكراني ولكن مدى مدى نجاح هذه العمليه
كان يشكل بها طبعا نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسيه مدريديف شكك بامكانيه ان يكون
لديهم القدره على اتمام هذه العمليه وقال
ايضا ان
زيلينسكي قد يكون في خطر الان بسبب عدم
امكانيته ان يقود الحرب حتى النهايه روسيا
تحدثت كما قلت لك ان لديها القدره
العسكريه القويه القادره على انهاء او
ايقاف هذا الهجوم المضاد وهذا ما سمعناه
على لسان وزير الدفاع الروسي الذي قال انه
كان هناك على مدى يومين يوم اربعه وخمسه
يونيو هجومان مضادان
نفذتهما اوكرانيا في سبع اتجاهات في في
المناطق في اقليم دونيسك ولكنها كلها طبعا
تم احباطها من جانب القوات الروسيه هذا
الهجوم لطالما المضاد طالما كان منتظر من
الجانب الاوكراني والذي تحدث عنه مرارا
الرئيس الاوكراني ولكن كما تقول موسكو
انها قادره على صدره وقادره على المتابعه
حتى النهايه في هذه العمليه التي بداتها
في اوكرانيا طالب من موسكو مراسله العربيه
دائما شكرا جزيلا لك كاتي على كل هذه
المتابعه
[موسيقى]
تدمير وسد نوبك خوفك في خرسون الواقعه
جنوب اوكرانيا له تداعيات اكبر مما يعتقده
البعض فعاد عن احتماليه تاثيره على امن
الطاقه في البلاد وغمره لقرى عده بالقرب
من السد فان له عواقب بيئيه كبيره صحيفه
واشنطن بوست الامريكيه نقلت عن خبراء
قولهم بان تدمير السد الاوكراني قد يغير
النظم البيئيه الى الابد وان التاثير
الكامل قد يستغرق شهورا او حتى سنوات
لفهمه تدمير السد الرئيسي ومحطه الطاقه
الكهرومائيه قد يؤدي الى تجفيف المنطقه
الزراعيه الغنيه في جنوب اوكرانيا واكتساح
الملوثات في المجاري المائيه وتقلب النظم
البيئيه التي نشات حول الخزان الضخم الذي
تتدفق مياهه الان
ووفق المسؤولين فسيؤدي تسرب مخزون المياه
الضخم من الخزان الى اعاده تشكيل خريطه
اوكرانيا وموانئها وسبل عيشها ما يعرض
المجتمعات التي تعتمد على المياه للشرب
وزراعه المحاصيل للخطر وبالتالي قد يدفع
ذلك الامر بالمزارعين الى التوقف عن العمل
منظمه غير حكوميه اوكرانيه حوالي 100 قريه
وبلده قد تغمرها المياه ومنسوب المياه لن
يبدا في الانخفاض الا بعد خمسه الى سبعه
ايام مستشار رئاسي اوكراني كبير كارثه
بيئيه عالميه تحدث الان وسيتم تدمير النظم
البيئيه ومقتل الاف الحيوانات في الساعه
المقبله وزير البيئه الاوكراني ما لا يقل
عن 150 طنا من النفط تسربت من السد الى
نهر دينيبرو والاضرار البيئيه جراء تدمير
السد نوفاكا قدرت بنحو ثلاثه وخمسين
مليونا وثمانمائه الف دولار الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش انهيار
السد كان كارثه بيئيه مع تدمير المحاصيل
المزروعه حديثا والفيضانات الهائله رئيس
تنفيذي لشركه طاقه اوكرانيه من المرجح ان
يتم تصريف خزان كخوفكا الى الصفر وعدد
الاسماك سينخفض تدريجيا
مع من عمال مزيد من المتابعه لهذا الموضوع
الدكتور فاضل الزعبي وهو خبير الامن
الغذائي في مركز جنيفا للدراسه دكتور فاضل
اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور فاضل للاسف يعني في
الحروب كل شيء مسموح على ما يبدو الحديث
الان عن كارثه حقيقيه كبيره حديث في محله
ام لا في مبالغه واستهداف السد هل سيؤدي
فعلا الى تفاقم ازمه الغذاء والحبوب محليا
وعالميا ام لا يعني لا يجوز تكبير الحجر
الى هذا الحد
اولا شكرا الك وخليني اخذ السؤال الاول
اللي هو الناحيه البيئيه نعم له تاثير
بيئي لانه بحيره بحجم 18 مليار متر مكعب
نشات حولها نظم ايكولوجيه وبيئيه محدده
الان اصبحت عرضه للجفاف واصبحت الى مجرى
النهر العادي راح يتم تغيير هذا التغيير
راح يكون واضح جدا خلال السنوات القادمه
ليس الان كذلك في موضوع مهم جدا الملوثات
اللي نشرت هذه الملوثات اللي اصبحت موجوده
في مجاري المياه راح يكون لها تاثير
على حياه الاسماك اللي موجوده عدا عن
الالغام اللي راح تطلع فالتاثير البيئي
موجود وبشكل كبير راح يحول منطقه الى
تقريبا شبه جفاف لانه الفيضان هو اكبر ضرر
بالزراعه من حتى عدم وجود المياه راح يصير
في انجراف في التربه وراح يكون في تغييرات
بيئيه كبيره اما السؤال الثاني حول الامن
الغذائي والغذاء في العالم نعم شويه
مكبرين الحجر لانه خلينا ناخذ الموضوع
بشكل بسيط قبل الحرب وقبل 2014 وقبل ما
تدخل روسيا على شبه جزيره الكرم في المره
الاولى هذه هذا السد كان اكبر مشروع مائي
وتقريبا ينتج 80% من خضروات اوكرانيا لكن
الان في ظل الحرب هذا اصبح معظم اراضي
اللي برويها السد هي في الجانب الذي احتله
روسيا اصبح هو المورد الاساسي للمياه لشبه
جزيره القرم والزراعه هناك وقليلا منه في
الجانب الغربي من النهر اللي هي فيرسون
والمناطق حتى اعطيك صوره عن الحجم
بحسب لسان الاوكران نفسهم وزيره صرحت بانه
هنالك اربعين الف شخص بحاجه الى عمليه
الاجلاء 17 الف فقط في الجانب 17 الف فقط
في الجانب الراني وخمسه وعشرين الف في
الجانب الجانب الروسي
بطبيعه الحال هي انتاجها الزراعي كان
متدني لنقل الى 40% بفعل الحرب والعمليات
العسكريه والان خلي يصل للصفر طبعا انا ما
بقول يعني لنفترض انه سوف يصل الى الصفر
هذا راح يؤثر لكن ما راح ياثر انا بوجهه
نظري على السوق العالمي لماذا لانه
اوكرانيا مع محددات التصدير لا تصدر كامل
انتاجها نعم طيب بالنسبه لما بنقول دكتور
ما علينا نشرح للمشاهدين ستتغير النظم
البيئيه المحيطه بالسد والبحيره ربما
لسنوات وسنوات وما الذي يعني ذلك طيب وكيف
سيتم تعويض النقص مثلا لنقل نقص الغذائي
هل لدى الفاو مثلا بدائل عن يعني عن مثل
هكذا نقص في في
السله الغذائيه انصح التعبير
هو حقيقه اول تاثير مباشر على وضع الامن
الغذائي هو عدد سكان المنطقه انفسهم سكان
المنطقه راح يكونوا عرضه الى او عرضه
وبحاجه الى المساعدات الانسانيه من الغذاء
والدواء ومياه الشرب بشكل
اثنين بالنسبه للتعويض في السوق العالمي
بالشهر الماضي مؤشر الفاون الاغذيه بين
بوضوح بانه الكثير من السلع الاساسيه كان
انتاجها اكثر من المتوقع وهذا
ظهر واضحا في انتاج الذره من البرازيل
والصويا من امريكا والقمح من استراليا
لذلك لا اتوقع ان
ما سوف ينقص من هذه المنطقه سوف يكون له
تاثير الا تاثير تجاري على حركه البورصات
بطبيعه الحال انت تعلم بان البورصه اي خبر
يشكل اهتزاز او عدم يقيني يؤثر على السعر
براي هذا التاثير لن يكون اكثر من فتره
بسيطه من عمان الدكتور فاضل الزعبي خبير
الامن الغذائي في مركز جنيفا شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاركه اعزائي المشاهدين
الان الى هذا المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير
الخارجيه الروسيه لنستمع الى ما يقول بت
نفيذها قدما هو في هذا العام فيروسبور
تقام القمه الروسيه الافريقيه الثانيه
وكذلك
المنتدى الافريقي الانساني انا واثق من ان
اللقاء على اعلى المستويات
لن يكون اقل اهميه من القمه الاولى التي
عقدت في سوتشي عام 2019
وكذلك سوف يتم وضع برامج
تطوير وتعميق التعاون ونحن ننطلق من ان
القمه الروسيه الافريقيه سوف تساعد
بوضع مسار تعاوننا خلال الاعوام القادمه
وسوف يكون الهدف الرئيسي هو الرقي
بالعلاقات الافريقيه الروسيه الاقتصاديه
الى مساواه اعلى وفي الختام اود ان اهنئ
جميع الحاضرين هنا بعيد يوم افريقيا
واتمنى لافريقيا السلام والرفاهيه والصحه
والعافيه لكل اصدقائكم واقربائكم وشكرا
جزيلا لكم
[تصفيق]
الكلمه
السفير فوق العاده والمفوض لجمهوريه
[موسيقى]
الى شان اخر فقد اعلنت الخارجيه السودانيه
ان قوات الدعم السريعه اقتحمت سفارات
الصين فلسطين ومنزل السفير العمري ولفتت
الخارجيه السودانيه الى ان قوات الدعم
السريع سرقت سيارات دبلوماسيه من السفاره
الصينيه وعبثت بالمستندات كما مارس
عناصرها التعذيب ضد عدد من عمال في مقر
السفاره الفلسطينيه بالاضافه الى اقتحام
منزل السفير العماني بحسب بيان الخارجيه
السودانيه
قوه الدعم السريع في السودان قالت من
جهتها ان الجيش قصف سوق المويلح بام درمان
جوا ما ادى الى مقتل واصابه عشرات
المدنيين ونشرت قوات الدعم السريع مقاطع
لما تقول انه قصف طيران الجيش لسوق
المويلح فيما لم يصدر الجيش السوداني اي
بيان يوضح تفاصيل هذا الحادث طيب
في المقابل عبرت مجموعه اصدقاء السودان عن
قلقها البالغ ازاء العنف المستمر والوضع
الانساني الكارثي الذي تشهده البلاد وادعت
المجموعه التي تضم السعوديه والولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي واليابان طرفي
الصراع في السودان الى الالتزام بالتعهدات
المتفق عليها في اعلان جده لحمايه
المدنيين كما طالبتهما بالعوده الى حوار
جده لحل المشكلات المتعلقه بالانتهاكات
والتوصل الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار فعال
ومستدام وضمان وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
الى ذلك كشف تقرير اللجنه الطبيه لحركه
العدل والمساواه في مدينه الجنينه عاصمه
ولايه غرب دارفور عن وضع ماساويا بسبب
الحرب
فقد اكد تقرير اللجنه وفات جميع مرضى غسيل
الكلى في الجنينه وذلك بعد خروج جميع
المستشفيات
والمراكز الصحيه عن الخدمه وانعدام وجود
اسطوانات الاكسجين والدم للمرضى
واوضح التقرير ان المدينه محاصره من كل
الجهات وانها مهدده بالعطش بعد انقطاع
الكهرباء والمياه والاتصالات الهاتفيه حيث
لا يمكن ايصال المساعدات الطبيه او
الغذائيه وقال التقرير ان وجود القناصه
داخل الاحياء السكنيه ادى الى صعوبه في
حركه الطواقم الطبيه التي اتخذت من بعض
المنازل المستشفيات مؤقته
وفي العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ما زال
الكثيرون محاصرين في منازلهم منذ اندلاع
العنف في اول مره في الخامس عشر من ابريل
الماضي حيث احتل المقاتلون بعض الاحياء
وسط المدينه واطلقوا النار من الاسطح وبين
المباني كما ان الكهرباء ما زالت متقطعه
والغذاء والماء شحيحين ووردت انباء عن
اعمال نهب وسطوا مع انتهاك العديد من
اتفاقيات وقف اطلاق النار التي اتفق عليها
الجانبان بشكل منتظم واستمرار القتال وفق
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه
معظم القتال في السودان يدور الان في
الخرطوم وفي المنطقه الغربيه من دارفور
يسيطر الجيش على معظم انحاء البلاد بما في
ذلك بورت سودان محللون عناصر من قوات
الدعم السريع تسيطر على معظمي وسط الخرطوم
وزاره الصحه السودانيه تجاوز عدد القتل
المدنيين جراء القتال
865 قتيلا واكثر من خمسه الاف جريح والعدد
الفعلي للقتله قد يكون اعلى بكثير
من الخرطوم لمزيد من المتابع ينضم الي
الدكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه وهو سكرتير
نقابه اطباء السودان دكتور عطيه اهلا
وسهلا بك اقل ما يقال عن هذه الحادثه
بانها ماساه موصوفه ومتكامله السؤال من
يتحمل المسؤوليه والم يقم بالمصطاع ولو
باساليب قليله انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذ ارواح
هؤلاء اقصد مرضى الكلى الذين توفوا
نعم بالتاكيد في البدء خالص التعازي
لجماهير الشعب السوداني وامنيات الصحه
والعافيه لكل الجرحى والمرضى وعوده حميدا
لكل المفقودين نعم بالتاكيد هذا ما ظللنا
نردده منذ اليوم الاول من هذه الحرب
العبثيه ان اوقفوا هذه الحرب العبثيه
الخاسر الاوحد في هذه الحرب هو الشعب
السوداني
الذي عانى ويلات الحرب واعان ايضا من
تبعاتها السيئه ما يحدث اليوم في الجنينه
وعدد من ولايه دارفور الاخرى يحدث ايضا في
عدد من المناطق او من الولايات الاخرى
واولها هو الخرطوم
كذلك يحدث بتكرار في ولايه شمال كردو
ولكن قبل يعني كان بالامكان مرات امنه
وتوصيل هذه المعينات الطبيه الى الى
المستشفيات حتى نتمكن من القيام بدورنا
الطبي والانساني كان بالامكان
يعني احترام المواثيق الدوليه وعدم مهاجمه
المستشفيات كان بالامكان عدم مهاجمه
الاطباء وطواقم الطبيه ووصل عدد الشهداء
وسط الكوادر الطبيه الى 19 شهيدا كان
بالامكان وقف اعتقال الاطباء على راسهم
واخرهم زميلنا الدكتور علاء الدين نقد
وايضا كان بالامكان وقف التعدي على
الكوادر الطبيه والاسعاف التي وصلت الى
احد عشر اسعافا تعرضها للاعتداء وايضا
انا افهم افهم ما تقول ولكن من يتحمل
المسؤوليه لماذا ترك هؤلاء المرضى لمصيرهم
حتى انت ذكرت يعني في كل اعمال الحرب وفي
ايام الحرب هنالك قوانين وظظم تحكم حتى
يعني تسمى قوانين الحرب خصوصا المستشفيات
والمرضى لماذا ترك هؤلاء
لمصيرهم وهل تركوا لمصيرهم بشكل مقصود
برايك
ما بعد الحرب ان شاء الله سوف تتكشف
التقارير ومعلومات اكثر نحن الان نتحدث عن
الجرحى من جراء هذه العمليات العسكريه
ولكن الذين توفوا في منازلهم لانعدام
الدواء والانعدام الوصول الى المستشفيات
اكثر بكثير من جرحى من شهداء العمليات
العسكريه
كان بالامكان النظام الصحي بالتاكيد هو
يعني مختل وضعيف حتى قبل هذه الحرب
العبثيه لذلك لا يعني
تسمع كثيرا عن توقف عمليات غسيل الكلى هنا
وهنالك في عدد من المستشفيات حتى هذه
المستشفيات التي لم تطلق فيها طلقه واحده
ولم يبدا فيها اي عمليات عسكريه
ولايه كسله على سبيل المثال عانت الامرين
وتوفي كثير من المرضى فيها الضغط على
النظام الصحي الذي كان يعني يعني يعاني
الامرين والان هو يوشك على الانهيار هي
واحده من الاسباب التي ادت الى استشهاد
هذا العدد الكبير من الشعب السوداني الذي
الذين نتاسف على فقدانهم نعم هل هنالك اذن
خطر على حياه مرضى مرضى اخرين سواء في
الكلى او في غير امراض
بالتاكيد نحن يعني نتخوف منذ اليوم الاول
نتحدث عن المرضى من كبار السن المرضى من
اصحاب الامراض المزمنه الاطفال الحوامل
حتى يعني المستشفيات التي تقدم خدمات
النساء والتوليد هي قليله جدا على سبيل
المثال في ولايه الخرطوم نحن نتحدث فقط عن
12 مستشفى هي تقدم هذه الخدمات وهو عدم
عدد ضئيل جدا اضف الى ذلك الوصول الى هذه
المستشفيات ايضا محفوظ بالمخاطر لذلك الحل
الاوحد والوحيد هو وقفه للحرب العباسيه
فورا وبدون ولكن يعني تعرف دكتور يعني نحن
لا نرجم بالغيب ولكن وفق التوقعات
والتحاليل انه هذه الحرب ستستمر هلا
السؤال
المطروح الان الا يوجد منظمات مؤسسات
دوليه تستطيع ايصال هذه المواد البسيطه
لانقاذ ارواح هؤلاء
بالتاكيد كل المنظمات ابدت استعدادها
وواصلت جهودها منذ اليوم الاول ومن هنا
لهم التحيه والشكر ولكن بدون
ممرات امنه لن يستقيم الحال لن تستطيع كل
المنظمات توصيل
المعينات الطبيه يسمعون و يرون يعني
اختطاف الاسعافات بما فيها من ادويه وبما
فيها من كوادر طبيه
كل هذه الهدن وهذه الاتفاقيات التي وقعت
لن تستطيع ايقاف اله الحرب ولم تستطيع
ايضا ضمان الممرات الامنه على الارض لذلك
اذا استمرت هذه الحرب وهو يعني ما لا
نتمناه
تاكيد سينهار النظام الصحي تماما
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من الخرطوم الدكتور
عطيه عبد الله عطيه سكرتير نقابه اطباء
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
نائب رئيس الامريكي السابق مايك بانس ينضم
الى السباق الرئاسي
اهلا بكم من جديد تنطلق اليوم في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياضه اعماله الاجتماع الوزاري
بين وزراء خارجيه دول مجلس التعاون ووزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه وذلك في اطار التعاون
الاستراتيجي الخليجي الامريكي وتعزيز
العلاقات الثنائيه بين دول المجلس وواشنطن
وكان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلنكن قد وصل يوم امس الى جده لبحث
التعاون الاستراتيجي السعودي في القضايا
الاقليميه والعالميه
سدد دبلوماسي اوروبي في تصريحات للعربيه
على انه لم يعد ممكنا العوده الى الاتفاق
النووي بشكله الحالي الذي كان على الطاوله
في اغسطس الماضي وقال ان اي اتفاق النووي
مع ايران يجب ان يتم التفاوض عليه منذ
البدايه واضاف الدبلوماسي الاوروبيه انه
لا يمكن اغلاق تحقيق المواقع السريه من
دون اجابات مقبوله من قبل ايران من جهتها
ابلغت السفيره الامريكيه لورا هولغايت
مجلس المحافظين بوكاله الطاقه ان اجوبه
ايران لم تكن مصحوبه بادله وان المجلس يجب
ان يكون مستعدا لمحاسبتها واضافت ان
الوصول ايران لايرانو مخصب بنسبه 83% لا
يجب ان يتكرر ابدا
قدم نائب رئيس الامريكي السابق مايس
اوراقه رسميا للانضمام الى قائمه مرشحي
الحزب الجمهوري للرئاسه الامريكيه لعام
ومن المقرر ان يطلق بانس حملته الرسميه في
ولايه اليوم وهي الولايه الاولى التي
ستدلي باصواتها في تقويم ترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري
ترامب المرشح الابرز للحزب الجمهوري يواجه
منافسه قويه مع مرشحين جمهوريين اخرين في
السباق الرئاسي الامريكيه العام المقبل
ابرزهم مايك بنس نائب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب
مرشح جمهوري اخر هي نكهالي والتي كانت
حاكمه سابقه لولايه كارولاينا الجنوبيه
وسفيره ترامب السابقه لدى الامم المتحده
عندما كان رئيسا للولايات المتحده كما
اعلن الحاكم السابق لنيوجيرسي دخوله
السباق الى البيت الابيض مقدما نفسه على
انه الجمهوري الوحيد القادر على مواجهه
ترامب حليفه السابق الذي اصبح من اشد
خصومه الان فيما رد ترامب على ترشيح
كريستي بالقول انه حاكم فاشل
في القائمه كذلك حاكم ولايه فلوريدا راندي
سانتوس المرشح الثاني الاوفر حظا بعد
ترامب بحسب استطلاعات الراي
وبعد ترشح ديسانتوس بشكل رسمي قالت ترامب
عنه انه سيحتاج الى عمليه زرع شخصيه
الى واشنطن تنضم اليه لمزيد من المتابعه
مديره مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه
البلبيسي نادي اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد
الانتخابي لدى الفريق الجمهوري الان وهل
مايك بانس يشكل تهديدا حقيقيا سواء للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ولكذلك ناديه
اهلا بك الطالب حتى الان روند عفوا
يحصل على فقط نسبه تاييد 5% هذا يعني بانه
لا يشكل اي تحدي حقيقي او جدي سواء كان
الرئيس ترامب او حتى
لكن هو يطرح نفسه كمحافظ كممثل للمدرسه
التقليديه التي كان يتبعها الرئيس رويجن
ويحاول ربما من خلال هذا
الترشح الذي اصبح الان يعني يزداد عدو عن
تسعه اشخاص حتى الان ان يجد مكان له وان
يقول بانه طبعا هو كان يتابع كل سياسات
الرئيس السابق دونالدز لا يهاجمه ومن هنا
يحاول ان يحتفظ بالشريحه التي كانت مواليه
للرئيس على امل على امل بان الملاحقات
القانونيه ربما ضد الرئيس ترامب قد تؤدي
الى ربما تغيير راي الناخبين الجمهوريين
او حتى مقدا قانونيه وبالتالي يكون موجود
في الصوره ويستطيع ان يطرح نفسه كمرشح
اساسي للحزب الجمهوري طيب بس مجرد ان يرشح
بانس نفسه الا يعد ذلك صفعه للرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب يعني انه نائبك عم يترشح ضدك
وهذا الا يصب في مصلحه ديسانتوس ناديه
يعني الى حد ما يمكن القول هذا لانه البعض
يرى بانه بالفعل كان هو مخلص للرئيس
بالبدايه مخلص للرئيس ترامب ومتبع لكل
سياساته وهذا طبعا البعض يعارضها وهو
يختلف معه طبعا في اللحظات الاخيره عندما
كان هناك اقتحام على مبنى الكابيتال ورفض
بنس ان يقوم بمصادقه على الانتخابات ويقول
بانها غير شرعيه وبالتالي هو موقف طبعا
اثار غضب الرئيس دونالد ترامب واعتبره
بانه غير مخلص وغير وفي لكن يمكن النظر
اليها من جهتين بدون ادنى شك بغض النظر
حتى الان لا نستطيع ان نقول بان اي من
المرشحين لديهم حدود سوى الرئيس ترامب حتى
الان يتربى على راس هذا الهرم ب 35%
والباقي هم ياتون دونه حتى نيكي هيلي
ومايك فينس وغيرهم لكن كما تعرف
بالانتخابات ليس الجميع يطمع حتى لمنصب ان
يكون مرشح للرئيس لكن هم يعرف يمكن ان
يكون هناك ايضا مناصب اخرى نائب رئيس او
غيره طبعا لا نتحدث عن ترامبوا نفس
السيناريو لكن اذا كان ربما مرشح اخر يمكن
ان يفكر كنائب للرئيس مره اخرى وبالتالي
هناك تكتيكات وحسابات سياسيه ومن هنا
يطرحون انفسهم رغم انه 5% لا احد يعني
يستطيع ان يقول بانني استطيع ان اوصل الى
ترشح الحزب الجمهوري بهذه النسبه المتدنيه
لكن هو يعرف تماما على الاقل بانه الان
نتحدث عن عام ونصف قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه وبالتالي كل شيء يعني
مفتوح لتغيير الحسابات وان يكون هناك
اشياء غير متوقعه ومفاجات
ولكن هذا لن يمنعني من يعني من سؤالي من
سؤالك عن نعم عن حظوظ نكهالي
يعني هل تملك اي حظوظ ولماذا يعني نشاهد
انه
معظم فريق ترامب الذي كان معه في في
ولايته يشهر السكاكين عليه الان هي كانت
سفيرته في الامم المتحده حتى كريس كريس
كان صديقه المقرب لماذا الكل الان يشهر
سكاكينه في مواجهه الرئيس ترامب
لانهم يعتقدون بانهم بامكانهم ان يحصلوا
على تاييد مؤيدي الرئيس هذه الشريحه في
الحزب الجمهوري التي يمكن ان تنقلب ضده في
مرحله معينه وباقي الجمهوريين الذين لا
يرون ترامب هو مرشح يمكن ان بالفعل ان
يخدم الاجنده المحافظه للحزب الجمهوري
وبالتالي هم يعتبرون بان هناك فرصه يرون
بان ترامب لديه الكثير من المشاكل
القانونيه والملاحقات وغير على انه طبعا
شخصيته بانه معروف بانه مثير للانقسام
والى غير فهم يرون فرصه بالفعل بالنسبه
لهم لانه بالنهايه يجب ان يكون هناك مرشح
للحزب الجمهوري لكن النقطه اللافته هنا
طاهر بانه طالب عفوا بانه لا يوجد هناك
احدا يهاجمه بالطريقه التي نتحدث عنها
بشاحه السكاكين سوى كريستي كريستي وهو
حاكم نيوزي السابق كما تعرف لديه مشاكل
شخصيه مع الرئيس ترامب وما عائلته حتى مع
جري عندما كان حاكم لولايه يجازي وهو مدعي
عام وبالتالي بدا هذه الحمله بالفعل يمكن
ان يدمر على في المناظرات السياسيه لكن
الباقيين يعني هناك بعض الخجول اذا اردت
السياسي من مهاجمه الرئيس ترامب بشكل
عالمي علني يعني يهاجمونه لكن ليس بحجم
الدمار الذي يعني بين قوسين الذي يمكن ان
يعني يترك اثره على الرئيس ترامب بين بعض
المرشحين او بعض الناخبين الجمهوريين من
قبل وهذا هو وزن السياسي ايضا انه لن يصل
الى ترشيح الحزب لكنه يريد ان يتخلص من
واشنطن مديره مكتب العربيه في واشنطن شكرا
جزيلا لك ناديه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
السلطات الكنديه تعلن عن خروج عشرات
الحرائق في الغابات عن السيطره
اهلا بكم من جديد اوقف الطالبان انشطه
جميع المنظمات المحليه والدوليه في مجال
التعليم في ولايه سربل الشماليه افغانستان
وذلك بحسب تسجيل صوتي للمشرف على اداره
التعليم في الولايه محمد كاشفي حيث امر
مسؤولي التعليم بايقاف انشطه جميع
المدارس في تلك المنطقه
مئه الف دولار فقط هي الحل امام
اللبنانيين للحصول على جواز سفر جديد فما
وضع جواز السفر اللبناني على لائحه اسوا
جوازات العالم راجت عمليه شراء الجوازات
في لبنان من جزر لا يتعدى عدد سكانها
عشرات الالاف هذه الجوازات تمكن
اللبنانيين من دخول الدول الاوروبيه بدون
تاشيره
على طرقات لبنان انتشرت اعلانات تقدم
حلولا لمشكله جواز السفر فالحصول على
تاشيره لصاحب جواز لبناني يحتل المرتبه
السادسه والتسعين بحسب مؤشر جيد لترتيب
الجوازات ليس بالامر السهل
وللمحافظه على استمراريه شركتها وتسهيل
اعمال عشرات الفروع المنتشره في الخارج لم
تجد داليا وسيله سوى شراء جواز سفر احد
الجزر الكاريبيه وانا المايتي كانت انه
بدنا نبقى بهالبلد بدنا نخلي مصنعنا بدنا
نخلي عيالنا بس بدنا نقدر نصدر الصناعه
اللبنانيه او المنتوج لبرا فمن هون طلعت
الفكره انه لا خليه يكون عنا
للماركت نقدر نفتح تشانلز لبرا لنخلي
عيالنا بلبنان بهالمصنع انتقل لزياد من
العمل في سوق العقارات الى تشجيع
الاستثمار في جوازات السفر الحصول على
جواز جديد مضمون هنا
الا يكون صاحب الطلب متورطا امنيا او سبق
وتم رفض منحه عددا كبيرا من التاشيرات
تحت امريكا
انه يقدر واحد يقدم على جنسيتهم مقابل
مصاري بيندرس الفايل تبعه وبينقبل وبياخد
الجنسيه هذا اول بارت هذه هي الجنسيه وفي
بروجرامات باوروبا
عندك باليونان عندك باسبانيا
في منهم توصل للجنسيه وفي اغلبيتهم الفكره
من هدول بروجرامات
هنيك ما تغيري شي بحياتك ويكون عندك فريده
مائه اللبنانيين وجدوا في هذه الخدمه
ملاذا فيما دولتهم باتت عاجزه حتى عن
تجديد جوازات سفرهم اصبحت هذه الجوازات
بوابه عبور اللبنانيين المقتدرين نحو
العالم اما من لا يملك المبالغ اللازمه
فيبقى السيره جواز سفر لبناني يتبول لائحه
اسوا جوازات العالم غنوه يتيم العربيه
بيروت
اخلط السلطات الكنديه اكبر مدينه في
مقاطعه كيبك شمالي البلاد ويعمل رجال
الاطفاء على مكافحه 150 حريقا في الغابه
من بينها اكثر من 110 حرائق صنفت خارج عن
السيطره
وحذرت السلطات السكان المعرضين للخطر
بمناطق الشماليه وشماليه غربيه في مقاطعه
كيبك بضروره البقاء داخل المنازل
وثيقه سريه سربت من شركه تويتر كشفت ارقام
ونسب عن ارقاما ونسبا عن مبيعات الشركه
توضح المازق المالي الذي تعيشه الشركه
الوثيقه بينت انخفاض المداخيل بنسبه 59%
على المستوى السنوي الامر الذي يخالف
تصريحات ايلون ماسك الاخيره والذي قال
فيها ان اغلب الشركات التي كانت تستخدم
تويتر كمنصه اعلانيه عادت للتعامل مع
الشركه وقد قام ماسك بتنصيب رئيسه تنفيذيه
جديده هي ليندا يا كارينو بدايه هذا
الاسبوع
لمحاوله انقاذ ما يمكن انقاظه قبل ان يصل
العصفور الازرق الى الافلاس ربما
النشره المفصله من العربيه نشرت الخامسه
انتهت اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات